dr nash in total transformation who is
sponsoring this next segment have been
transforming lives all across the valley
today we're going to look at some of her
incredible success stories
dr nash it is great to see you and today
is one of my favorite topics we're doing
success stories and some amazing before
and after photos and some amazing
journeys but one of my favorite success
stories is yours once i discovered what
it was in my body that was going wrong
and adjusted and fixed it that's when
the 80 pound weight loss happened and
that's when it finally held and that's
what we do for people like we're going
to see today
yes and let's start with let's take a
look at kimberly's success story 17 and
a half pounds 26 and a half inches the
evil back fat is gone thanks dr nash i
love kimberly's energy and the thing
that she said there too the evil back
fat it's gone like that stubborn fat you
got rid of it we got rid of it so she
lost 17 pounds in 30 days which is
already accelerated but think about this
jc she lost almost 27 inches off of her
body in a month so this is because we're
focusing more on fat loss than just
weight loss so they shrink to these
incredibly small amounts
you know the inches are even better than
the fat loss but yeah beautiful okay
speaking of shrinking everybody take a
look at veto on dr nash's program i lost
170 pounds and this is the result
i mean i'm speechless every time i hear
vito's story 170 pounds the guy had to
go out and buy brand new pants obviously
but what a success for vito well veto
was actually updated because he lost 140
pounds and then we keep in touch with
our clients and so we kept in touch with
vito and found out how's your life going
he's like i lost 30 pounds more so this
is really important not only do we help
you fix the problem but we teach you how
to fix it for good i mean he lost a jc
he did
didn't you tell me a story once with him
and this is a great story he was grocery
shopping and his pants fell down because
he just lost so much weight he went
north and the pants went south yeah
i love that that is great okay everybody
take a look at laura's story when i
started with dr nash i weighed over 300
pounds and i was pre-diabetic since
being on a program i lost over 130
pounds and i no longer have that
pre-diabetic threat dr nash these are
life-altering results that you're doing
here laura's journey just incredible
yeah and laura's journey is similar to a
lot of older women who are blaming their
weight problem on menopause we hear that
all the time with older women she
thought it was menopause too she did
have a hormone problem but it wasn't
menopause it was dietary hormone she was
pre-diabetic when we reversed the
diabetes the weight dropped off
are these results typical for most of
your clients
they are typical when you follow the
program and the protocol the way i build
it for you if you try to do it on your
own most of the time you're just not
going to get results that are this
amazing or changing now dr nash every
week you bring a great special what do
you have this week
so of course when i come on the las
vegas now show i want to give something
special back to the viewers normally my
online evaluations are 97
but if you say that you saw me with jc
and if you go to the website that we're
showing on the screen i have 10 spots
but only 10 available at 9.97 over 90
off let me see what's going on in your
body that's stopping you from reaching
your results and help you turn it around
thank you to total transformation for
sponsoring this segment visit
doctornash.com forward slash eval to
take advantage of her special offer
we'll be right